from lounges to hotels to the dozens of
Valley dispensaries the need for skilled
cannabis workers is high
at the local and very competitive
cannabis industry as it continues to
Boom now Ryan Matthey shows as a
community college taking students from
the classrooms to employment
nowadays you can't go too far from the
Las Vegas Strip without seeing some kind
of cannabis dispensary or marketing here
on Desert Inn you got the reef
Dispensary on one side of the street the
other side you have Planet 13. these
college courses working to put locally
owned and grown workers inside them and
it starts here everybody wants a
professional that knows how to handle a
product their online courses that hit
the College of Southern Nevada this year
Advanced manufacturing cultivation and
Retail areas of the industry that's
helped it grow to nearly a billion
dollars in Nevada and courses that could
give locals a foot in the door and if
we're going to continue to diversify our
economy we need talent that's going to
help diversify that and it's actually
very competitive it's provided through
the college but taught by green flower a
proclaimed leader in cannabis education
that's already teaching at over 30
schools Nationwide the hiring managers
and the people that are building these
companies really need people who have
some existing background or skill set
because there's too much to learn and
understand from scratch this as
dispensaries have become commonplace and
consumption lounges and hotels are in
the works I believe that Nevada will
lead the nation in this area around
cannabis consumption lounges and every
one of those people will need to be
thoroughly trained in order to
participate in that sector and at the
end of it an employment Network helps
students get a job there are people that
live here raise their families here and
this is another career path for them to
contribute
now each Corps certifies students in the
respective field that they choose their
eight week long programs with open
enrollment meaning anyone can apply and
begin when they want to it'll run
prospective students about 750 dollars